[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat Bambi on I'm Kevin spell
of Bernard
remember I used to work here
lovely to be back man but let's just
[ __ ] address the elephant in the room
y'all didn't need me man mark [ __ ]
killed it while I was away oh you're too
kind
with his insanely racist show black back
yeah all I got on the road were report
after report of oh my god this is great
and then the defendant [ __ ] then the
[ __ ] got mean with like don't come back
he's doing it he's killing it everyone
has loved it man how's that [ __ ] feel
you got it here I'm just gonna set the
stage for Jesus it's lonely in here man
I can't even see anybody yeah really but
it's not my kind of smoke I it made me
so happy because like Mark Oh God you
know I was I was I'm this kind of guy
that does this [ __ ] where I'm like oh I
just want talking I want people to look
at me and [ __ ] mark was not necessarily
that guy maybe in his heart you were in
a band when you were a kid I was in a
band when I was a kid so I we sucked
don't worry about it well I would still
be in a band if we didn't suck seeing
him kind of like coming to his own so
much so that like [ __ ] people like
that [ __ ] I saw a lot of that was the
best show that you guys ever did and you
weren't there maybe that's the key stay
the [ __ ] away and but it was really
really [ __ ] great man that may be so
proud what it feel like to become as
just an entertainer no it it was fun it
was fun getting to do the thing that we
kind of sort of do which is like just
stand up here and talk about the [ __ ] we
love and I did get oddly possessive
we're like I think Katee Sackhoff wanted
to come and stand where I'm standing and
one of me stay where you're standing I
was like that's not how this goes Kate
yeah
no you're sleeping on the wrong side of
the bed Katie which is again a sentence
I never thought I'd say but I like to
say
came out of your mouth awfully
comfortably six I think I think yeah we
had Malcolm Barrett
we had Todd stashwick Katee Sackhoff
well you guys broke down Watchmen we
broke down the first three episodes of
Watchmen and that was where who was who
made the joke that was like Watchmen
it's so black Liam Neeson's looking for
it mouths an amazing [ __ ] joke that's
that's the end of that run like you
can't top that it really is yeah the
premiere night hold my beer [ __ ] it was
awesome I'm so glad you did it but I'm
happy to be back I've missed this place
I've been in front of a lot of people
I've been out on the road with a Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Roadshow tour and I've
seen Jamie Jamie has been at how many
too many stops I've done here just to
set the stage I've done 37 cities so far
37 yeah thank you
and it was sixtieths show in LA so 37
and 60 how many cities did you go to 15
shows total but ten cities ten cities 15
shows you are literally the only person
going to this [ __ ] tour man oh it's
always nice and good to see a little
piece home and I'm always reminded of
the show and then I'm like wonder how
the show is doing then people like stay
the [ __ ] away sure don't need you I'm
like Oh shows doing great I guess so
it's been fun out on the road but like
nothing like beats this audience the
intimacy of this room and stuff like
that how we get to geek out it's just
really [ __ ] cool on those road shows
I spend a lot of time obviously talking
about myself and the movie specifically
and [ __ ] why I made it so it's so
it's a big meat fest and the bigger the
movie is a huge [ __ ] me fest and stuff
come in here and just talk about other
people's [ __ ] Fanning out that feels
like the right relationship because
that's how I started this [ __ ] just as a
fan so it feels nice to be back be able
to geek out
[ __ ] first thing I want to geek out
about before we dive in anything else
cuz we got a bunch of [ __ ] to do the
ending of Watchmen and and just for the
record because I know you guys deep tove
all of the Watchmen was my favorite
[ __ ] thing this year and that
includes my own movie
I looked for at first I was like who the
[ __ ] like one a week [ __ ] this noise but
then I started to like learn
anticipation again like when we were
kids where you were like and then you'd
spend all week
like literally obsessing about it I
watched those episodes five times like
I'd watch it twice the night it dropped
and then throughout the week it would be
my go-to if I woke up early and had time
I'd sit there and smoke and [ __ ]
watch it it was a dream come true it was
everything that you'd like we talked
about as kids going like imagine if
somebody took this [ __ ] seriously but
Damon Lindelof rather than just going
like oh I'm gonna give you the watchman
that you know he's like I'm gonna show
you the watchman that I was inspired by
and to me it [ __ ] fits I can't speak
for Allen more but like how could you
not love what it became and like it's it
was insanely [ __ ] groundbreaking it
captured my imagination it felt like The
Watchmen without being the Watchmen any
they didn't overdo fanservice
but there was so much of it that it made
me absolutely delighted you could see it
was made with loving [ __ ] hands every
episode was thrilling to me and this is
how good it was like my wife hates
everything and like she watches all true
crime programs that [ __ ] out of murder
her husband which is really [ __ ]
unsettling if you're a husband and [ __ ]
and you're her [ __ ] husband so she
loves that like true crime and she liked
that courtroom program she was like I
was like hey let's watch Netflix has
this thing about and really Lucas she's
like sawed twice like it just [ __ ]
came out man so like she watches that
[ __ ] when I'm like hey do you want to go
see like you know [ __ ] iron man she's
like call me when it's iron woman she
one of those [ __ ] people so Watchmen
she only watch cuz we had a fight and
she was trying to make it up to me and I
was just like well I want to watch
Watchmen I think it's [ __ ] brilliant
I've watched three episodes she's like
you get mad at me if I watch something
without you and then you won't watch it
with me I was like I know but you're in
the dog house so you have to [ __ ]
watch my program and so I'm rewatching
it with you that's how [ __ ] good it
is and stuff and she doesn't know the
book I mean she knows it exists and
stuff like that and over the years she's
picked up stuff from Mithraism [ __ ] but
she doesn't know the source material she
absolutely loved it she's like it's
[ __ ] dense but like this is
incredible to be fair she's the world's
biggest Regina King fair oh [ __ ]
Russian I mean like I loved her going
way back to boys in the hood remember
she was like she was just an obnoxious
extra that woman built an amazing
[ __ ] career from like a character
performance in that movie cuz that goes
back preemie so I was 95
25 years ago with clerks so Jon had two
boys in the hood three four years before
me I feel like it's 92 so she's been
added almost [ __ ] 30 years man she's
on two to seven yeah are you [ __ ]
man so it's like the older daughter and
duties that she [ __ ] elevated that the
series man she was so pot committed and
what a thrilling story I'm certainly not
gonna retry the the territory that you
went through but like I if I was [ __ ]
thrilled that it was like wow I've never
seen this before it's a very black story
what the [ __ ]
must have you felt every episode like I
imagined every episode I watched I was
like [ __ ] I wish I was home because
finally something he'd have nothing bad
to say about
he was loved every second of this and I
was so scared to text you to be like do
you like watch me because I didn't want
you to shatter my illusion [ __ ] yeah
like [ __ ] this is some white man
[ __ ] [ __ ] Damon Lindelof Oreos
black on the outside why don't he
outside I mean honestly it was B I
couldn't [ __ ] my breath was taken
away is if I felt like I'm seeing
something insanely [ __ ] new and they
took all familiar tropes and remixed it
like it was and not just like from
Watchmen like you know [ __ ] you know
you don't have to know comics to be like
hater putting a baby in a basket and
sending it away from a world that's
[ __ ] falling apart and [ __ ] like that
and then they like mail at home later on
because I remember watching that - I
feel clever and then in Episode seven
they're like everyone's clever now they
[ __ ] just show you the bad guy making
a bad guy speech the way bad guy
speeches do huh
and also the whole series I'm like what
the [ __ ] with Jeremy Irons and they
landed it man where I'm like what the
[ __ ] with Jeremy Irons like that was
awesome and I'll sit through him [ __ ]
like farting and getting his legs rub
there whenever a [ __ ] just to get to
that moment when he sees Laurie for the
first time like face to face and he
calls her miss Jim is no he said miss
juspeczyk
she's basic the name from the comics guy
cuz polish or something like that and
her mom's weird mom she's Sally just
Bezeq but she changed it to Sally
Jupiter cuz she wanted to Anglican eyes
or something like that so him [ __ ]
calling her by like her truly secret
identity because now she goes by Laurie
Blake I [ __ ] came so hard like I was
sitting there right next to my wife the
whole time and I kept I swear to you
nine times during that [ __ ] last hour
I kept doing this [ __ ]
she's like nobody's here to see you I
was like that's how [ __ ] good it is
man like I stand this [ __ ] yeah what did
you [ __ ] feel about like before we
get to the finale what at what point
were you like holy [ __ ] they made this
just for me
like two minutes into the pilot holy
[ __ ] right you know did you know that
story prior to that I I knew that I
didn't know what merely that deep and in
that depth but I I had heard like when I
was a kid about Tulsa the Tulsa massacre
and it just you know like a thing that
my parents and said I was a kid it
doesn't register at all with you and you
kind of just move on but never touch
Center in school never was a touchdown
as the thing you like a thing a parents
say to you what did they say don't ever
[ __ ] go to Tulsa man bad place but uh
you know it was probably some like
[ __ ] Martin Luther King birthday and
we're having like that like black
history because they're not really
teaching in school so let's just talk
about the reasons why people have dreams
and oh by the way oh [ __ ] let's talk
about this and I'm like in the midst of
all the dreams here's a couple thousand
[ __ ] nightmares it's a horrifying
[ __ ] story did you see today's news
yeah that they found like a mass grave
from from Tulsa from the 21 massacre
they said reported like there's 36
reported deaths but they were like there
were hundreds and now they think this
mass grave might reveal that I mean it's
the one time that it that a that a
domestic terrorist group conducted an
airstrike that was crazy when I saw the
planes that's what made me go to the
Internet I'm like come on and then I was
like holy [ __ ] and it's a story that you
I've never heard my entire life - open
your show with that yeah predicate your
entire series the declaration of intent
oh my god right away I was like you have
my attention
look I was all in anyway I wanted to
watch this but suddenly I was like oh my
god like that was the first [ __ ] like
instinct or feeling where I was like
he's he might do this like he might pull
it off because I remember when they were
like we were doing a series and it's
kind of spin-off was set in the future
and [ __ ] I was like why would you bother
why wouldn't you just [ __ ] do the
Watchmen and do it right and [ __ ] you
didn't have to they did it it was in the
background they [ __ ]
even gave you the goddamn squid and more
squid on top of it man like oh it's
[ __ ] I mean cuz you know Alan Moore's
watchman is about nuclear holocaust
right and Dave Gibbons and Dave Gibbons
it's in the shadow actually if you watch
to credit Dave Gibbons Watchmen yeah but
it's the that was that the the
overwhelming social and political issue
of the day well yeah ours Russia going
to nuke us and that's all we thought I
mean if you weren't alive in the 80s it
was everywhere it wasn't cover it you
were scared of that [ __ ] like you and in
fact you thought you were just gonna die
in a nuclear war one day it seemed
inevitable
you know it's oh my god now that I think
about it like recently I was looking at
the news cycle and I was like feeling a
little hopeless like everybody does
because sometimes like the stories just
stack up like Jets where you're like
come on man somebody put up a [ __ ]
puppy story quick and [ __ ] and I was
just like this must be the absolute
[ __ ] worst like time to live in a
news cycle and [ __ ] like that it's so
depressing but that was a pretty [ __ ]
bleak time yeah no it was awful like
everywhere you looked and you didn't
even have Twitter to offer you puppies
it was just the [ __ ] news
yeah off and they were like you're gonna
die you're gonna [ __ ] die man because
Russia you're gonna [ __ ] die
hate the Russians ate dying and I
[ __ ] hated dying and [ __ ] still do
yeah I'm not a fan I didn't beat that
out of me man
but so so in order to update Watchmen
you know Damon and he said plenty of
different places yeah you talked to me
yeah I talked to him last week I think
what was that for
the writers guild foundation had a
writers on writers sort of conversation
with Damon about about Watchmen and they
asked me if I would do it and I was
[ __ ] ya hear you've heard man it's
been [ __ ] nuts I'm sure Damon had said
like well what's what's the prevailing
sort of social issue that we're all sort
of wrestling with at the moment and for
him it was race for him it was you know
the like with the rise of Donald Trump
and the rise of the alright and we're
talking about Nazis again and we're
talking about white supremacy again the
sort of the bleeding
wound of America that American ever
really wants to deal with that America
hides under its own mask of civility is
race and and so he's like I want to do a
show about that I don't know anything
about this so I'm gonna find people who
know things about this I'm going to
consult every text I can and like hire a
writers room who I feel will challenge
me to have these conversations about it
and pushing that show into a zone that
not only dealt with race but dealt with
with pain you know it's fundamentally a
show about pain and legacy and the
legacy of pain and and to have an
episode like Episode six where you are
literally going back into the Noren of
hood of justice and what motivates a
person to put on a mask and what
motivates a person to hide who he is for
a certain reason and to have levels of
masks that you're wearing like I'm a cop
but I'm also hood of justice and I'm
also gay and I'm also black and nobody
can know these things so I can do this
work that I feel like I'm prompted to do
and also that episode just visually
stunning as well with like masterful
touches of like Street had the white
eyes she had he had the white the white
eye mask she is the black man like
generations of crime-fighting everything
was just so so the I don't want support
we can talk about that as well it's
gonna [ __ ] we've all seen it yeah
right yes most kind of ish alright
the the egg motif the egg motif really
absolutely [ __ ] brilliant man how
they built up dr. Manhattan
throughout the entire series where you
know he was like the shark in Jaws they
don't give you the shark in Jaws right
away takes an hour for you to see him
[ __ ] swim under the boat and [ __ ]
they waited pretty deep into their run
to be like alright here is his race like
lots of things in that show I've been
hiding in plain sight yes the entire
time and that bit and the finale I'm not
going to spoil it but you know like
there's a statue that we've seen that is
something like you [ __ ] yeah
you put it like I've been looking at
this and that's that [ __ ] you most of
that show me watching was [ __ ] you in
jealousy of like mouth god damn it I
can't write anything I never felt
jealous I've never felt insecure because
I was like wow [ __ ] I'm they're all
brilliant [ __ ] but I just felt like a
fan the whole
time I was like oh my god that [ __ ]
rocks oh yes that's the that's how you
[ __ ] do it
like I couldn't imagine that [ __ ] I
couldn't improve it honestly there's
nothing more I'd be like if they had
done this like they hit everything
[ __ ] great like even like they
checked every box and tied up every
loose thread and left a very satisfying
conclusion and also left a completely
[ __ ] open-ended to do a completely
different story if they want to do it
again if they did it again
I'd be elated if they never did it again
I'd still be happy like it is honestly
the best thing I saw all year I was so
deeply invested I thought it was
imaginative I thought it was it felt
important watching it it made me smarter
watching it you know I remember like in
the beginning fall in love with it right
away but then being like well you know
it's Damon let's see if he sticks the
landing and stuff he stuck the [ __ ]
landing like my hat's off to him and
it's it's [ __ ] it's it was absolutely
[ __ ] one of my favorite thing made by
human hands this year man yeah yeah will
not see it's like can you like honestly
can you think of another first season of
television that there was that [ __ ]
strong one Maude you know what he's got
us
[ __ ] Maude was pretty amazing man I
was she didn't have an abortion you're
right [ __ ] Maude I think I think I
was stopped dead I was like did he mean
Maude Maude I think the first season of
Battlestar yeah yeah but still like
alright and I'll give you that but as
great as the Watchmen know I mean it's I
have never seen a show engineered as
finally and precisely as this show no
like a watch like a watch like every
[ __ ] gear is waiting for its mesh and
everything is in its moment and it's
time and setups and payoffs are organic
and surprising and everything is obvious
and everything is surprising all it was
and a satisfying conclusion - yeah like
I wasn't sitting there going oh come on
like they I'm telling you stuck the
landing
[ __ ] point was addressed
I was completely [ __ ] satisfied right
right down to like how people stayed
completely in character there's trace
stayed true to their characters spoilers
Lori making an arrest at the end yeah
like felt absolutely true like made
absolute [ __ ] sense yeah and like
every everybody was operating from an
emotional place Adrian Veidt does what
he does because he wants to feel loved
and can't and it's like I want to feel
loved by a world that I think I saved I
want to feel loved by these [ __ ]
weird as Europe Europeans that's good
god they're working at a whole different
level bad and like for him to to
potentially never get that love like
every Damon story feels like a tragedy
and and being lost bid the leftovers be
it this but it's finding those moments
within that tragedy that make it worth
going through anyway and this is to me
the most crystalline version of that is
that we see the tragedy of it and we're
told it's gonna be a tragedy and we'll
you embark on a story knowing it's going
to end badly
yeah oh that was so [ __ ] beautiful
like especially I loved that it looked
all the episodes were going but that
episode God walks into a bar even was
it's like clever [ __ ] title just
putting it that way that made me cry
that episode when and when you know he
was like she was like who says is it him
he says like aren't they all like give
him every yeah there's an every stone
each watcher is there every love story a
tragedy
and she was like you got me there yeah
and it's the most it's the greatest
meet-cute story I've ever seen because
it is nothing but these two people been
getting a relationship but you're
dancing throughout time and you're
seeing the ramifications of it you see
the lengths to which this person will go
to fall in love and be surprised by love
and the sacrifice of that and and the
weird manipulation on her part of like I
can create the perfect man for me I
picked out the perfect body because you
I if I could choose I'm picking [ __ ]
yaaaa well you've seen that dude's dick
yeah I seen it a lot
my wife watched it too and she was like
is that special effects I was like [ __ ]
yeah it is man that's a numbered CG
nobody that well huh match to the Light
& Magic look he's all blue he ain't blue
in real life trust me I of man oh man
yeah that was you know what I didn't
even care I didn't even care that his
[ __ ] dick was so thick was to seize
that it made me question my own [ __ ]
manhood going do I even have a dick for
real that's how good it was I was like
you could put that big blue dick in my
face I love your show the last episode
him experiencing all those moments at
once was [ __ ] heartbreaking for a guy
who had to deal with the tragedy of
constantly existing across time at one
span at one moment for it to all be like
the best moment like the greatest
[ __ ] hits that was incredibly
touching I hated to see some characters
go I'm trying not to [ __ ] spoiler but
it was so [ __ ] beautifully done and
there's also like technically for that
character he never has to die because
he's always living those moments all at
once and so he's chosen his last moment
to be all of the best moments with her
and that's how he will forever be
remained is in this little loop there so
awesome lovely romantic Valentine's Day
loop forever and ever and ever because
everything is nothing and nothing is
everything to that dude it was so human
nature so much he delivered a like a
sci-fi comic book finale as well that
had brains to it but it's the one
episode that feels the most like a comic
book right down to like there's a
ticking clock and [ __ ]
and we're gonna use a [ __ ] ion a
cannon on the trapped him in this
[ __ ] cage and stuff like that I'm
going to destroy him and become him I
love the lady true secret origins
I loved such a weird flourish where he's
like he's never had sex but he saves all
those [ __ ] [ __ ]
it just it was such an Ozzy mandiant
thing to do in a vault that's fronted by
a picture of Alexander the Great
yeah little [ __ ] like that man like and
just all of it so so imaginative and
inspired by the source material without
stealing liberally from the source
material like there's a bunch of bow
magis but like I never felt like all
he's just doing that he didn't there was
no giant squid it wasn't like we're
gonna do it again I love their plan I
thought it was original spot like the
idea that like we're gonna find we're
gonna [ __ ] capture dr. Manhattan and
destroy him and become him and like
having lady trugo like can you imagine
that power in the hands of [ __ ] white
supremacist like it it it felt like dire
stakes like I Adam I've no what I can't
think of another movie gamma book
property TV show where it was just like
we have to stop these racists from
becoming super racist and just he did
the true job of a superhero and he did
it without all that help the
heartbreaking relationship with Captain
metropolis and [ __ ] and having that dude
be like come on come on you're just
that's all in your head and [ __ ] and
having him single-handedly take down
like a secret society of [ __ ] true
supervillains all of it was so [ __ ]
masterfully done man it was it's like I
remember like when we should when the
Batman came out in 89 and like you could
get people who weren't into comics to
watch that movie and you were like see
man it's not just [ __ ] kid stuff like
you could give the Watchmen to [ __ ]
brainy people who [ __ ] on comic books
still to this day and it's it's just it
stands apart as a piece of like media
that doesn't honestly rely incredibly on
its source [ __ ] material you can
watch that without ever having read
watch yet and it still works they give
you all
just enough of the backstory and like
anything hopefully it inspires you as it
did me to go back and [ __ ] read the
Watchmen again all throughout I was like
oh [ __ ] I want to know just it deepens
it oh like knowing the hood of Justice
origin story just makes all of that [ __ ]
far more resonant now and also in point
of fact the first and third rate Indiana
Jones movies are about keeping racist
from becoming super races [ __ ] good
call man that's a good point yeah
they've done it before all right [ __ ]
Watchmen it was fantastic
and boy I'm gonna miss it like yeah the
same as much as I was like I want to see
what happens it really [ __ ] I was sad
when there was no next week I'm Watchmen
and [ __ ] although like Damon has gone on
record both in lots of other places and
with me I asked him like are you gonna
make more of this and he said I don't
have another idea for it and until I
come up with another idea for it I have
no interest in doing it good good I mean
like [ __ ] I backed that plan yeah but
don't make a weak version HBO did say on
the series finale of Watchmen meaning
like they are fully intending making
more of this so season finale that
season as the series yeah you read
between the lines so yes so like they're
making more of this with or without him
but I pity the fool who attempts to
follow this without the idea you know
cuz this cant be a we gotta make one
like if they can make nine episodes of
magnum p.i surely we can make two of
this I don't know all right this is all
about TJ we could stop sucking
watchman's dick it's so big dawg I know
and lucious I need help
is like you know that joke throws like a
baby arm hole not best [ __ ] literally
was a baby's arm holding an apple it was
so [ __ ] I was like ever see do you
never see one that big
I was in college once yeah and also
that's that's a Black Manta yeah it is
and talk about like a completely
different a completely different
performance like Black Manta performance
is all aggression and [ __ ] his cow is
all inners n and peace and totally yeah
like yeah well a very cow yeah yeah and
his get down you remember him from the
get down
did you ever see he's in the get down
who plays like a [ __ ] disco Godfather
it's great like who is this guy yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm doing my team ii
yeah uh he's got a name you don't forget
a name like i Abdulle Mattia second
that's your apparel yeah you're just
[ __ ] showing off Wow yeah he killed
it he absolutely [ __ ] crushed it man
like I know it's not like you know man
there's so many people who played that
role but I thought Billy Crudup did a
great job but I thought this guy did a
[ __ ] yeah fantastic I mean yeah it's
so much more to worry about - yeah like
more time to get into it more time to
lean into it and no I guess that's all
we're gonna said about Watchmen yeah
yeah I could talk about I went to the
Star Wars premiere last night yeah you
did official premiere the rise of
Skywalker uh the good folks at Bose
headphones gave me these Sith headphones
and tickets to go see the movie and
stuff so me and I took my two wives
Jason Mewes and Jennifer Schwalbach one
on each arm and ship and man they it's
there's only up here at that China
wasn't that technically the Chinese I
guess it'll be Dolby yeah oh my god it's
true a whole time I thought were going
to Chinese does they shut down that
Street but we wound up going to the
Dolby and I was like oh [ __ ] is that
where they do the Oscars I was like I've
never been in here I'll never be in here
again and the
but then I remembered I was there once I
went to see a ballet you can see I know
the kid was like into ballet so my
wife's like we're all going and I fell
asleep and then this is the [ __ ]
Oscar room a show like that so you they
think it's an engineering miracle man
they shut down a bunch of streets and
[ __ ] corral traffic and so that they
can bring people through security that
was the big [ __ ] deal man
every car went through the bomb check
and dogs surrounded it and stuff like
that and you realize oh I guess this
place is a big [ __ ] target because I
was wondering why they didn't announce
it they were like we're not telling
anybody where the premiere is gonna be
but I live up the street from the
Chinese and we did a show at the Chinese
the other night and so right outside we
saw the [ __ ] setup we were like jeez
I wonder what's gonna happen here so
that they were keeping it quiet for
safety and stuff so they checked
everybody and everything and then we got
our tickets and walked in and you walk
in like what street was it was
completely shut down so [ __ ] I can
get you anywhere in this town but if you
ask me the street names of my god
so Highland did they shut down highly
Ohio no they shut down we all it would
Boulevard Hollywood Boulevard and then
what's the one right behind it yeah
where the high school is that was when I
brought people through and that Selma
and then they brought cats into the
grounds where there was a giant room set
up that once you got inside look like
Space Mountain because it was all black
but I had stars poking through and they
had giant x-wings and ships and [ __ ]
like that
in the press and they had the 501 the
five-oh first the Legion was there
filling up the middle and stuff so
there's a lot of enthusiasm first person
before I even got inside stepped onto
the carpet and then peeking out from you
know well first I saw his lady I saw
Mary Lou and I was like aha
man where's your man she's like oh he's
over there and there's Mark Hamill
peeking out from behind the wall and so
me and Jay ran over
to him for a while and stuff he was
lovely but he was just like he's like
I'm nervous
he's like things like this are really
big he's like I'm just I'll be here for
a minute so he was hanging it off to the
side we should chat it with him and [ __ ]
then I went inside and I saw JJ inside
and talked to him for a minute I saw
Adam driver who I didn't remember this
but my casting director on cop out was
like you met him he came in on cop out I
was like he dodged a bullet but I got to
go up to him and be like hey man how are
you and [ __ ] and he goes nice to meet
you so he didn't [ __ ] remember me
maybe so it was mutual but I was like
you are you're just doing career-best
work right now Matt congratulations and
he was like thank you he's very serious
he's like thank you this is my wife
classy dude like introduces a wife
because I got a wife who like is always
like you never introduced being [ __ ] and
so I was like you should marry Adam
driver Manny buddy once he gets divorced
yeah maybe not maybe don't marry him in
the movies but in real life and [ __ ]
maybe that's why I introduced me to my
his wife he's like this is my wife
that's only a [ __ ] movie you know I'm
good at this yeah he's like we [ __ ]
got a good thing going on so I met him
who else did I see I saw Greg Grunberg
but I'm good to talk to him
I John Favreau I ran into and I was like
I look I said I have not seen the show
yet because I've been on tour so I'm
waiting two episodes and I'm gonna be of
the binge the whole [ __ ] thing I said
but like I can't avoid [ __ ] baby Yoda
man it's everywhere I'm sure I was like
that shit's brilliant
I said who came up with that and he goes
and I go
are you serious he goes I wrote the show
I was like you're the [ __ ] showrunner
- he's like I saw mine I was like you
came up with baby [ __ ] Yoda man as it
would have [ __ ] like you should have
held a copyright to that [ __ ] man as the
baby Yoda is gonna heal the world
he's very happy right now in life he
said some of me that made me feel very
good he goes he goes oh my god you're
everywhere and I was like the plans
working but then he gave me like the
coin that's from the mandalorian it's
his like challenge coin yeah and on the
back it says executive producer
something like that if ever it's his
coin and stuff I was like man I hope
this is good for a cameo so I saw him
then who else's I'm s all like john-boy
came over and he goes I know that guy he
was on the set and I was like he
remembered and who else did I see when I
was in the theater I saw Harrison Ford
man was a guest I looked over and
[ __ ] I was like is that [ __ ]
Harrison Ford and it was Harrison Ford
and then there was a dude next to him
and I was like is that holy the [ __ ]
and it was Steven Spielberg and this is
what I saw was one of the most charming
[ __ ] moments man like you know I was
many rows away I could have hit him with
a wiffle ball but it would I would had
to throw hard and [ __ ] but he was
standing next to him and at one point
Harrison Ford here move over Harrison
Ford is like talking to somebody and and
here's Seema Spielberg next zone and
then Harrison Ford goes oh they're boys
man like [ __ ] there are hundreds of
years old but they're [ __ ] boys
they're tight with each other they've
been in each other's lives forever it
was really [ __ ] sweet I saw Billy Dee
live in the flesh they introduced
everybody brought everything everybody
up on stage the big takeaways I'm not
allowed to talk about the movie but the
movie I really we I really [ __ ]
enjoyed it better all positive but we're
not allowed to speak about it I haven't
seen it so I can't he can't sign ASIS
didn't get to go along with the two
wives I mean I did have two wives but
the my big takeaway for that evening
other than the movies wonderful is JJ is
like could do what I do in a heartbeat
he is very funny his timing is like
[ __ ] impeccable
you know everybody at the premieres
rootin for you so the audience's in your
pocket [ __ ] but he has legit comedic
timing like where I was like that's
[ __ ] unfair you can't be the guy
that's like good at these movies and
like do my job
you know like [ __ ] I get to make the
week movies and be the guy with the
microphone and they put a microphone in
his hand he's [ __ ] wonderful man I
didn't want the intro to end I was like
more [ __ ] Jay Jay at one point in the
movie though thank God they started the
movie because there's lots to love in
the movie at one point in the movie
something happens that's so big that
[ __ ] like nah I'm not only was like
the first to start applauding and I knew
it before it happened I could hear it
off Cameron [ __ ] and then it happened in
[ __ ] as everybody was applauding then I
[ __ ] as soon as it died down I
screamed at the top of my lux [ __ ] yeah
Jay Jay like and [ __ ] punch people
chuckle and Cheer like that it was it's
it's a ride it's an epic movie that
[ __ ] brings not only a trilogy to an
end but the [ __ ] saga to an end and
[ __ ] like that and my childhood to an
end instead yeah man it's [ __ ] big
and there's some wonderful [ __ ]
fanservice in it like really hardcore I
can't I don't want to say anything more
but it could because I want to keep
going to these [ __ ] shows and if I
spill [ __ ] before the [ __ ] date then
they don't invite you back instead would
you just spill nothing either man yeah
yeah oh yeah I want to spoil it so
hardcore there's so many things I want
to like just shout out and be like they
[ __ ] did this can you [ __ ] believe
they did this like there's some really
like no we haven't seen it we can't
believe it
shutting it it's small man
no yes
do you hear the call of the darkside the
Sith Lord over here is like do it let
your hatred strike down the spoilers all
right that won't spoil [ __ ] but I'm
telling you there's bring your bring two
pair of drawers man because there's some
fanboy and fangirl moments that are
[ __ ] wonderful fanservice McHale OTT
of boxes it's it's amazing that he
brings this burden for a [ __ ] landing
as well as it as he does like it's so
many strands that he ties together and
[ __ ] and come on let me just tell you
the one thing no [ __ ] you guys I can't
wait to come back and talk about it when
everyone has said it I am I am in the
thing I love the thing I want to spoil
no it's a it's a chewy thing I do I want
to tell you something all right
okay you know what wouldn't do we do
this again do we do it again before the
end of the year we don't this is the
last time there's a last time I mean we
can do another one if you want Ken why
is there enough time what if we did one
between Christmas New Year's about
anybody go if we don't between quick
what are you here
no I'm back east oh so maybe it'll be
white man beyond
[Applause]
white man beyond as a terrible rain to
it but I'll leave you talking about
watch many times it's like James Barr's
in his ear this Cyclops he's right here
we're gonna talk about white man beyond
no time
my next guest Clancy Brown snot Brown
what why are you going back to Jersey
uh yeah Jersey New York [ __ ] how long
eight days oh you're the problem it's my
fault I [ __ ] it up for everybody work
cuz we're like a week from Christmas
it'd be crazy to do it what is Tuesday
Christmas Eve yes
Wednesday's Christmas Eve or Tuesday
Wednesday's Christmas Day and we do the
show on a Tuesday we do we can't do it
on Christmas Eve like all our families
would hate us so much we couldn't like
the afternoon to do it do it I mean just
like I just so we can all [ __ ] talk
about the movie and [ __ ] I don't know
we'll figure it out if we just on
Saturday do like say week two we could
book a Sunday a Sunday afternoon look at
you see him backstage how she it happens
Sunday Sunday the 21st good people my
second that'd be three shows in a week
would people show up if we're talking
about star wars would people show up
that's the thing we'd be it'd be like a
spoiler affair we would just everyone in
the room would had to have seen the
movie cuz we're just gonna yeah we could
do that we could [ __ ] take everybody
I mean I don't know if I get actually
Sunday we're not gonna be able to get
[ __ ] a movie theater on Sunday
because it's like opening weekend yours
is I'm a plain assembler you're born a
day after Christmas whose gift to you
Shannon's gift and why did they get it a
day late that's beautiful maybe we could
do that 22nd we could do what's that
that's Sunday Sunday the 22nd will you
put it up and see what happens I mean
look 30 people show up at least we're
all getting to talk about
movie no I'll put it up tomorrow we'll
see you buy these tickets um well I'll
just bill it its rise a Skywalker
spoiler show smart [ __ ] yeah that's
smart tell them like everyone you have
to have seen the [ __ ] flick because
we're gonna [ __ ] talk it talked about
it alright that's good that'll scratch
an itch man because pocket I really want
to talk I'm gonna go to the Legion em
good folks Legion em who helped us make
Jay and Silent Bob reboot they're doing
a big screening on what is it Thursday
Thursday with the folks lining up dotnet
where we did the fat man beyond the
other night and stuff so I'm gonna go
watch it again because I watching in the
premiere was lovely and stuff but like
I've just come off the road where every
night we watch my movie with a bunch of
hardcore fans and I've described the
experience as like it's like going to
church where you're both the priest and
Jesus at the same time too so as
religious as those screenings have been
I want to go to somebody else's church
so to speak and going to the Chinese to
watch that the last [ __ ] Skywalker
movie man the rise of ska Garba the last
movie in the skywalker saga with a bunch
of [ __ ] hardcore fans and [ __ ] it'll
be thunderous and I've seen the movie so
I know what to expect so I won't be like
shut the [ __ ] up I can't hear the
dialogue so I'll be able to join in and
[ __ ] but I was the loud one at the
screening man like I honestly like
whooped hollered and [ __ ] called out
get like a lot throughout the movie
somebody I saw somebody tweeted like
last night I forget who it was but they
were like I was sitting a few rows in
front of Kevin Smith and he made the
movie so much better for me so there you
go take me to the movies
so alright let's do that so it looks
like Sunday we'll do a show all right
that cleans our up front [ __ ] it does
should we do a guest guest and then news
just in the news all right and then is
there a lot of news or no as much as you
want it can be as thick as a dick or as
small as it is biggest [ __ ] Joss dick
oh my
just don't quit [ __ ] who watches that
watchman me I watch his dick very
closely there are artists in the world
ladies gentlemen and there are artists
one of my favorite [ __ ] artists on
this planet man one person that made me
love the medium not just of comic books
with graphic art in general one of the
few artists whose work proudly hangs in
my house and in a couple different
variations man not just in his character
study of people who I've reading about
characters I grew up reading about some
of the drawings include my [ __ ] self
and stuff this is a name at which every
knee should Bend if you loved and we all
did spider-man into the spider verse
remember I talked about and we all did
remember I talked about like I was so
breathless about their rendition of
kingpin which I was like I swear to you
it looks like it's the kingpin that
comes out of love and death man that
dare double-book [ __ ] love and death
and I couldn't believe like somebody was
smart enough to choose and then the the
whole sequence with the [ __ ] collider
and [ __ ] like that looked like the do
stuff and I was like all thank God some
there's finally [ __ ] stealing from
people I love and [ __ ] like that
this guy has laid so much [ __ ] track
in the world of comic books and and
again I can't express how much of a
[ __ ] fan I am it's an honor to talk
to the great Bills GABA Jazeera lays
down
[Applause]
Thank You everybody happy happy almost
holidays almost at the holidays man you
got a [ __ ] strong Instagram game you
keep putting up some great [ __ ] [ __ ]
every day
you put up at least one thing that I'm
like like a breathtaking piece that I
know and love [ __ ] so well well I
can't take any credit for that that's
actually I got we got somebody do I got
yeah guy who paid the right [ __ ] dude
man but it's all your work like oh yeah
I'm calling from your [ __ ] catalogue
and everything they put up is it's just
a walk down memory lane for me and stuff
like that how long you been doing this
oh man if professionally I think that's
a I think I started in 1980 so it's been
it's been a long time I thought I know
that I've been drawing since I was you
know I started out like it's the cliche
you know taking my mom's lipstick and do
it and on the walls and stuff like that
but I've been doing this for for almost
15 years almost 50 years yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah and I I love it more than ever man
I feel like I'm still getting my my you
know the right the right idea of what I
want to try is coming up it's like it's
it isn't here yet I know that I know
it's out there somewhere you don't
meaning wait you don't feel like I'm
there I've done it oh no not at all I
mean I feel like it's always just so
elusive you know it's like I love I love
comics it's the medium for me growing up
loving comics as I did it's like and
then finding out about fine art and
abstract expressions of a jazz and
everything else when I was in art school
in Newark New Jersey it was like all
this stuff it was like that was such a
learning experience for me about art and
music and film and because I love comics
so much I felt like that was my calling
I remember I was seven years old I told
my old man I said I'm gonna be drawing
comic books when I'm you know when I was
seven years old I said I'm this is what
I'm doing
my life and I think he really started
pounding the sauce after that like
really really heavily but so I feel like
the medium could do anything and that's
that's the way I've sort of viewed it
and so the idea of like taking all of
his other stuff that that I fell in love
with and putting it into the medium it's
been my goal I was either going to get
out after the whole Adams clone thing I
don't know if anybody's familiar with my
past in terms of my influences but I was
a big Neil Adams guy yeah so and then
once I started doing moon night which is
what I started on and the book was my
first yeah first book those before New
Mutants and stuff yeah yeah how long
before how much further afield I think
was like three years I think I worked on
Moon Knight from 80 to 83 and then I
think I started doing a couple of other
covers like the Dazzler cover I think I
did star-lord one sort once or twice and
then I did dune in 84 because I was a
big David Lynch Frank Herbert fan and
pulled the police so they sting is in
the mix - why not and then they show you
the movie in advance were they super
secretive back they were very secretive
about it but but I dealt with that with
Universal and they gave me a bunch of
reference but I remember again loving
the medium and loving comics and also
loving the source material change
hearing you talk about you know Watchmen
and the source material and variations
and deviations there up the idea of
falling in love with with Frank
Herbert's Vladimir Harkonnen and they
were like you know I wanted to do
animation style you know obesity of you
know how he could float and everything
else so I was exaggerating a lot of the
stuff from the film Universal came back
and said you know you're making him way
too heavy it's like and Kenneth Vick he
doesn't look like Kenneth Macmillan
he's got pustules on one side of his
face you're putting him on both side of
his face so it literally came down to
negotiations with Universal art
directors about like all right I'll I'll
make him
thirty pounds lighter but you got to
give me 15 pustules it's like it was
that kind of negotiation and because you
know all of the comic book adaptations
of films over the years it's like doing
the adaptation of the Batman movie and
having to have Jack Nicholson be the
Joker it's like the Joker is the Joker
you know and so there's all of these
likeness clauses and it's comic book
movie adaptations are by nature and
thankless gig you know but I did it
because I was just a masochist it's like
I got it - dude I'm a David Lynch not
you know a lot of what he did an eraser
hate his stuff I tried to do in the New
Mutants and stuff later on so it's
[ __ ] up when you mentioned jazz cuz
instantly I'm like holy [ __ ] like I see
it in the artwork oh very cool electro
SACEM just feels like like [ __ ]
Coltrane oh thank you yeah it's
interesting you mention because I I
would listen to Coltrane as I was
working on that you know so yeah it's to
me a lot of a lot of what is you know
the medium can do you know a netbook if
I sound like a like an evangelist for
comics it's because I absolutely am you
know you a kid that gravitated toward
the dream job because you love the
medium in the first place you're still
in the medium you still [ __ ] like
rocket today as opposed to like some
catches as a springboard to something
else but you're like this is where I
want to be yeah and and even though I'm
doing stuff for you know I mean I've
worked with you know been fortunate
enough to work in a lot of other you
know related arenas you know in terms of
animation I mean with you know like
Carmen creating like the look for Carmen
Sandiego we're working with Eastwood on
Unforgiven you know which is which is if
you if you actually look at my into my
Twitter feed it says author artists that
Polish guy that Polish guy comes from
Clint Eastwood because when I was
working with him on the on the poster
art there were a number of different
artists who were working on I came up
with like seven different comps for it
which are preliminaries
and they wanted the art director wanted
to do a photography which is ultimately
what they went uh when ended up going
with but they said well what would
artists do you want to give it to and
eastwood said give it to the polish guy
and I was like I said I don't care if I
get this gig or not the fact is I've
just been insulted by Dirty Harry my
life is complete you know so all of
those other arenas like again like the
you know spider-verse I had no idea they
were doing that oh then they didn't hit
you up and say anything no I they
actually that the first I heard of it is
when they call me up to do a poster for
the release and and then they invited me
to the premiere which I didn't I wasn't
able to make it to but I ended up going
to the to see the film by myself which
is probably a good idea because I ended
up you know kind of crying into my
popcorn you know because I was just
blown away so they did you on the screen
like yeah it looked like you know yeah
it was it was pretty stunning and kind
of took my breath away it's like you
have to understand it's like I'm I'm a
farm kid from New Jersey it's like you
know my grandfather was a coal miner in
Pennsylvania I still view what I do as
being you know not necessarily in the
mines but like you know I'm I love what
I do I'm a working guy and all of that
other stuff that happened in terms of
you know Eastwood or the movies like we
just mentioned her or TV stuff that's
all kind of gravy but it's a I'm like
the the you know convert like the
comedian who has a you know a a lucky
break with the TV show but still feels
the best and the most at home when he's
standing in a crowd just onstage just
with a microphone
I mean I'm that that guy where the my
world exists you know to the extent of
my fluorescent lights the way Marvel was
the first company that hired you yeah
although I did try I didn't think I was
good enough for Marvel so I ended up I
was in my second year of our school all
my friends were graduating I go to art
school I went to school in Newark New
Jersey it was actually an art college
and in a music college I mean
Savion Glover went you know what there
Melba more if you've ever heard of
Melbourne or okay yeah so I would sub
you know you know just blown away by by
what I was learning there and then did
they recognize like early on with I like
this kids good like when did you know
you could draw
well the first time I knew that I had
something that was a little bit
different yeah was in kindergarten when
we had to draw and again forgive me for
the sort of you know cultural
insensitivity but we had to draw an
Eskimo you know at the time and I would
just remember doing a black crayon
drawing of this figure and an anorak you
know what the fur thing and all my
friends came up to me and I said how did
you do that and I thought you know when
you're five years old or four years old
you think everybody can do what you do
you know you don't you know you don't
think that anything is unusual and then
when I realized that you know I looked
at all of their work and I realized that
that that they couldn't I was like I was
like this is this is my jam you know I'm
running with this and it became an
absolute obsession and it still is it
still is it I'm sure you know we can you
know you guys it's like you know I think
your true bad obsessions I'm sure you
know who are the first artists that you
fell in love with like at seven at seven
years old when you decide I'm gonna do
this for the rest of my life who are the
ones that you kind of read and well I go
this is Neal Adams working at that point
were you really yeah actually severely I
was a big Kurtz wand Carmine Infantino
fan when I was because again with with
DC Marvel was a little out of my league
at that age
although I think I did read Thor but a
lot of the you know sort of cos DC stuff
felt safer it was a little more
pedestrian and like you know easier to
grasp it wasn't quite as like in your
face is like Kirby's stuff and that's
why I decided that I wasn't good enough
to get into Marvel that's why I went in
tomorrow into DC with a portfolio that I
I got together from May to June and I
just did all of atoms as characters you
know so I but I ended up going into
DC I didn't have a an appointment you
know I just basically put on a you know
a suit that was entirely made of like
petrochemicals you know there was all
polyester at an Eiffel Tower type plant
pants you could play checkers on and I
just went up there and just waited and I
watched a the receptionist like kind of
eat her way through like you know from
noon to two three o'clock just through
boredom like shooing from pretzels to
potato chips to you know and finally I
think they took pity pity on me and I
met Vinny Caleta and if anybody knows
who Vinny Caleta is he was an inker at
at Marvel and DC he was the art director
and he actually said I could hire you I
like your stuff but I don't think he'll
be working wrong because there's there
was the implosion which to this day I
still don't know what exactly happened
you know at the time but he called it
Neal Adams and he said you know I want
you to meet this kid and I went I walked
over to continuity Neil looked at my
stuff and Neil had his own label at that
point yeah I continued he was also doing
a lot of stuff for advertising yeah I
know so he obviously still had quite a
bit of pull so he called up Jim shooter
and shooter he said there's a guy I want
you to meet as a kid and problem is he
draws like me which of course it
everybody else was sort of doing the
clone thing and growing up in the in the
country the whole idea of you know other
like farmers that I was around going
like you know your work is really good
but you really should be doing your
wrong thing you know it's like there was
none of that right you know
people knew that John Deere was a
tractor and I think they thought that
Norman Rockwell was a competitor it was
that kind of thing they didn't know art
from anybody right so so I visited I
wonder what 2d to Marvel and they they
basically I thought I was I was hoping I
would my goal for the day was maybe I
can get a critique maybe I can get a
pinup maybe I can have them look at my
stuff and say look come
back in six months come back in two
years nothing happens at least I got one
more year of art school that I can go
into and what happened was is that I
walked out with basically a career so
and the thing is I started working at
Marvel with nothing but DC characters in
my portfolio when anybody tells you it's
like you know you got to play by certain
rules it's like if anything it's sort of
just you know I was too ignorant and too
unafraid to know any better I just sort
of it might have tipped the scales in my
village we got to get this kid out of
DC's hands man
yeah well well it would be that would be
you know I mean Vinnie Caleta had a big
hand in that though yeah but Marvel you
know was a like I said it was a little
too crazy for me but but DC stuff Curt
Swan I was a big fan of when you started
doing the covers for a lot of the DC
stuff I really felt I hated it I
absolutely despised it it was like this
was not it was unsafe you know it was
and I think some you know you might have
your own experience and other and fans
might have experiences of things that
you're that are in their comfort zone
and then somebody comes in a band will
do things and you know like the early
Beatles from the later Beatles or you
know or like everybody knows Led
Zeppelin with stairway to heaven and
then you listen to some deep cuts with
other stuff or or coal train or jazz or
whatever it's like when they when they
push you're you're a Reno your arena of
comfort and you kind of wonder is it
that I've gotten older and just sort of
under more understanding of stuff I
matured to like it because I used to
hate it now I like it it's like you know
who changed in the equation here and it
finally I at one point everything just
sort of switched for me I just fell in
love with Neill stuff and again growing
up in a very rural area I was like I
want to follow this this guy's ability
and so I just kept following and pushing
it and I wanted to I didn't want to draw
his own stuff I didn't want to copy his
stuff but I wanted to draw with
passion and ability that he had and and
it was until I went to art school I
discovered like I said music fine art
everything else that I just said wow
this is all this stuff I can I can
pretty much put down the funnel into the
goose that is comics you know when was
the moment when you went to an art
director and said I want to do something
different like I I know that you're
familiar with the kind of stuff that
I've done like early on and a new night
what and what have you the stuff that
might have felt a bit like a like a Neal
Adams cloned when were you like I'm
gonna take the training wheels off and
I'm gonna just [ __ ] go for it that
what prompted that well don't
underestimate the the power of anger you
know and in visit and feeling invisible
and unappreciated
I realized it because that's the New
Jersey and you might drive a
[ __ ] but a really 25 years or 50
years it certainly does man it's like it
and that's that's you know I I love
having grown up there it's like I Love
New Jersey but it was like when I when I
left I was like okay it's like thanks
you know it's like you know it's like
thanks for hanging tough for uh for
Springsteen thanks for all that all the
summers down a good Barnegat Bay you
know doing all the clams like burnin
steel but I'm never [ __ ] yeah exactly
yeah
but yeah I think I started getting a lot
of negative response
you know Bilson cabbage looks like you
learned to draw from Neal Adams you know
ellipses period and so I started to feel
completely invisible and you know I wish
somebody had like come to me and said
you know you got to do your own thing
when I was a teenager but of course that
doesn't happen so I thought all the
stuff that was I was putting in my
sketchbooks all just like to me it
seemed like I fell in love with fashion
illustration you know exaggerated
figures you know ralph steadman curse of
the low no I mean Hunter Thompson was a
big a big writing influence
me Tex Avery Chuck Jones I mean all of
that stuff that was just you know so
bizarre and and so I had my sketchbooks
full of that stuff and I remember I
talked to my wife at the time like I
want to try to get this into comics and
they were like you know she and and
other people I knew for Marvel were like
it doesn't happen like that you can't do
it and I thought I'm so fed up with the
whole dismissal of the Neal Adams stuff
that I'm either going to do comics the
way I want to do them or I'm gonna get
out it was like it literally became that
Stan Lee approach remember he almost yes
comics and and Joanie was just like just
write one for you if you're gonna leave
[ __ ] knew what you want to do before
you leave and that was Ben and for me
that one was hit it it was like I
plotted that and that was the one where
I really kind of wanted to do a comic
story where Moon Knight was not even the
main character he was just sort of you
know the guy on the cover that that you
know sold the book but it was really
about a guy not without it would not it
with a cape on or anything else he was
just some guy who you know kind of like
a lot of abuses it as a kid in the story
and I already always felt that you could
either take what life hands you of terms
of lemons you know or worse and you
could either feed that anger and just
pay that forward in which case you're
kind of you know just perpetuating a
shitstorm or you can actually do
something positive with it and just you
know he'll you know and I pretty much
wanted it to do that and I set it
against a sort of a musical backdrop and
so that's what I tried to do with with
hit it and you know what you mentioned
about I felt like I had nothing left to
do with Moon Knight it was like I was
done and then I was offered the x-men
and I turned it down was it's like okay
this is Marvel's flagship book yeah it's
like you're asking me to drive it into
the ditch because I want to try stuff
and I said give me a book that not many
people know
it's like because I'm really trying to
do stuff that I'm not sure about I don't
know where I'm going with this all I
know is that I need to experiment and
try things and I don't want to be
responsible you know so I started doing
more covers or more painted covers for
like the Dazzler and a couple of other
ROM and have other other books and and
then Chris Claremont stopped me in the
hall right outside of the x-men office
and he pitched me the three issue demon
bear saga like literally in 30 seconds
and because it was a dream sequence and
it was sort of this fantasy thing I just
thought okay this is three issues I can
do I don't want to do another series
three you know like I don't know how
Kirby or any of those guys did like
hundreds of issues I mean for me 30
issues felt like a lot no but when I
went when Chris mentioned that I said
okay I'm in and then we just had so much
fun you know with the with the series
that was just kind of kept on going with
it and speaking of which and I don't
know if I'm even allowed to mention any
of this but I I will say that the New
Mutants film if you if you've heard it
anything about it and followed it I saw
the trailer and the the last couple
years well actually uh two days ago I I
heard from Josh Boone the director and
it sent me a new trailer and they've
been working he's been working on and
everything else and it is phenomenal
yeah yeah it I got chills
it's like it look it looks like because
of the whole Disney Fox I don't even
want to call it merger take over
whatever you love you
absorption yeah right Borg the Borg you
know but it's got the blessings of
Marvel and it feels more Marvel in terms
of what they're doing but also it the
horror elements of the film are like in
place and it's it's really absolutely
stellar just what I've seen so I think
it's coming out I'd ever get they
haven't liked mention the exact release
date but you know
very excited about it you get to see it
in another medium a lot of characters
that you have brought to the fore well
even with all yeah what exactly with all
the actors I mean I was actually on set
a couple of years ago and I mean I'm not
a parent you know I mean I'm I was the
crazy uncle you know but or the you know
but or the Godfather kind of thing for
for kids but I pretty much told the cast
I said you know look you know nobody
[ __ ] with you it's like when I'm around
so you know they're they're all amazing
I mean for everybody from Harry's Agata
Maisie Williams to on your killer joy to
you know you just name it everybody's
just phenomenal really phenomenal so I'm
hoping the film does well for know what
the reason I like that trailer
ya know you have I got to volume like
crazy career retrospective book coming
out it's actually three volumes as well
I think did I give you
where's the book oh no that's okay it's
actually so it's over there's one oh
this one the blue one yes is that it up
there you got it yeah
Oh Jeff it's revolution and so there's
three volumes sorry but I got to sign it
for you guys but yeah it's a it's a
three-volume set this is Volume one
so so what went into choosing I mean for
three [ __ ] volumes for fifty years of
a career that seems like there's a lot
to choose from
well II narrowed down over the years
I've had different publishers you know
want to do a kind of a career
retrospective but because I've worked in
comics and in other arenas six-foot
publishing they're phenomenal they
actually do a lot of stuff with the
Museum of Modern Art and I'm not even
sharing it I'm just like look it's my
entire childhood so uh so they actually
you know pitched the idea of doing three
volumes and you know and doing things
that have to do with you know some of
the commercial work I've done some of
the fine art work I've done to kind of
cover
the encompass everything about the
medium that I love and about art in
general yeah yep is that what was it
shakin of the shadow yeah they brought
me DC actually hired me to do the shadow
after but they wanted it based on shaken
version the run yeah so so I ended up
haven't you know I mean I thought when
they asked me I was going to be doing
like kind of an electro sass and painted
series right because I sort of felt that
every series that I took on after Moon
Knight Moon Knight was sort of my
getting in on the Trojan horse like I
was doing very typical comic-book stuff
you know the Neal Adams very safe then
at the end of the series I started
pushing it New Mutants was sort of black
and white versions of abstraction then
electro sass that was taken out and put
it in color straight toasters was kind
of going even further out in terms of
you know collage and and other things
and I thought well I'm pushing it
further out the last thing I want to do
is kind of go backward and when they
asked me to do the shadow I assumed it
was going to be painted and I would be
able to play with it in the same way and
it was after I signed the contract that
they said oh by the way it's like none
of that we want we want you to do black
and white or you know line art kind of
like don't do any that crazy that's
enough to throttle down after being like
oh yeah I guess you could put it mildly
yeah yeah I felt I felt burdened down
you know yeah I felt completely sort of
you know hamstrung it was like you know
this [ __ ] don't work for me you know but
I'd already signed the contract so I
turned it into an exercise and in sort
of inking and you know trying to you
know again make lemon meringue pie with
the lemons but but it's still something
I'm really proud of and I'm working with
Andy and and you know shaken and I you
know we get along great so it's like
we have a really kind of funny who is
the Landy
Andy Helfer she's hot damn it I love
that [ __ ] run to them yeah who
followed you
Kyle big how big yeah that's [ __ ]
right yeah I loved I loved the child a
series I loved the Andy help her [ __ ]
run of that book well I think in a lot
of respects if you did that a whole
[ __ ] run yeah I love that run and
what you're telling me is you're like I
hated doing that yeah well I let's put
that way I initially I really hated the
sort of conditions but after I got into
it I accepted it for what it was it was
sort of like when you're when you're
handed something you kind of go well
this isn't what I expected it was going
to be it's different but you might have
be disappointed at very at the very
beginning but you kind of grow into it's
okay this is gonna be this is not gonna
be sterling steak this it's not gonna be
it's gonna be hamburger but it's gonna
be really good whatever it's you know
and again that's not even sort of
denigrating hamburger you know it's so
um but L Helfer was a really great
writer but I felt that as much as what I
enjoyed what I did and as much as I
enjoyed working with Andy I really felt
that that the shadow didn't click with
that run until Kyle took over what's
interesting is that Kyle like if you
felt hamstrung it it looked like that's
where he got to [ __ ] flourish and
start Kyle Baker in it up yeah what's he
I think Kyle a little more abstract
Kyle's a little bit more like like it's
like he's a he's a his just did like
running rampant I think that you can't
ride a hamstring Kyle you know I mean I
might have felt more like I was willing
to negotiate and be disappointed or
whatever Kyle's like [ __ ] this I'm just
doing I'm just and Kyle will just do it
you know Kyle is so fast and there's
just like a freedom to his work that by
the time you tell him you can't do that
he's like three issues ahead you know so
I worked with with Frank Miller on that
Darrell a book what was it like to [ __ ]
me on loving Ward where his scripts low
what was
script like well we actually wanted to
work together on love and war which was
going to be issues that was supposed to
be issues of in the devil in the devil
or run it was and I thought it was very
much into like I said tech saver and
animation I just wanted to do the
kingpin as this behemoth you know just
this large you know creature and we hid
pages from Jim shooter in Ralph
Macchio's office so we were basically
going to just you know we just conspired
pretty much to just like let Jim see it
and make readies when make readies are
when like everything is all together and
the covers aren't really on it yeah it's
good it's like one literally one step
away from being on the stands right and
people would come into the office look
at it Ralph would sort of like safeguard
the whole you know flat files and Frank
and I we'd look we loved working
together and he said we're going to do
this series but we should probably do
know this came later I'm getting ahead
of myself so what what happened was
shooter walks in the office one day in
to Ralph's office and we're all sitting
there and people are looking through
pages and Chris Claremont is looking
he's got the pages in his hand and Chris
goes hey Jim have you seen these and you
know the [ __ ] beans yeah he was like
not a not in daredevil yeah
well Jim Jim he looked through them and
he said would you come with me please
bill yeah he took me into his office and
he said no no this is not gonna happen
it's too it's too far out of continuity
it's just it's just too crazy he said
however with the death of Captain Marvel
the book that was done by Starlin yeah
became really really big in terms of
opening up the whole graphic novel
market he said you and Frank do this is
a graphic novel never there in the room
he said it no he said to me and then he
then when when Frank and I talked I said
look this is the deal and we were
ecstatic about it so Frank and I got to
and we talked about he said all right
we're gonna do this is a graphic novel
this is gonna be the big deal we're
going to be doing we need to do it
another series to put like basically
bread and butter you know something that
we can do to it will kind of keep the
money flowing in while you're knocking
yourself out on this painted stuff I
figure maybe an eight or six or eight
issue series on Elektra and I said okay
that's cool but I want to paint that too
and there was no painted you know comic
book right and this is again all pre
digital all that stuff you know it's
like like when I would tear pages in
half and literally use like needle and
thread to sew the panels back together
to show Elektra sort of you know kind of
coming apart at the seams no pun
intended you know it was I don't know
what to charge you per page well there
was there was no painted page right so
they just give you the day what I said
they said we only have you know the the
painted the page rate for coloring of
comics was based on what was usually
make like make readies and color Xeroxes
where they would have dr. martens dies
you know forgetting for people who don't
know what what you know what this
process was like where they actually do
guides for the for the pages where they
would use like black would be CMYK you
know it would be like K would be like
25% black whatever so would have these
different kinds of numerical codes and I
think it was $50 a page which is what
they were paying the colorists and they
said we only have that great established
and I said all right I'll do it for that
so I got holy [ __ ] it was you know again
this is that the passion of youth is
like I didn't care about the money I
just needed to do it I just needed it
was like it was groundbreaking yeah but
you got to keep those pages though right
and then I kept the lecture assassin and
then and then years later it was it was
actually all of it was purchased by by
Kevin Eastman when he hid the turtles
Kevin even bought all the lectures acid
although we had it at the Museum for a
while yeah yeah always would have this
Sam and Northampton you know what can't
count book musician fantastic got a
Batmobile there yeah from Tim Burton's
Batman yeah and the Turtle outfits and
[ __ ] but just a lot of legit comma
Bogart and would showcase like artists
oh yeah it's like kids so much of roseto
Jeff Shaw I mean he had one of the
largest collections and I think it it
eventually I think got kind of scattered
to the winds you know so you broke it up
I think I can visit occasionally some of
the people being out here in LA now
there are some of the execs that I know
who are big comic book fans you know so
I can like gave Mandel yeah did the
clerk's cartoon where they has a lot of
Frank Miller's Dark Knight Regis oh yeah
he's a lot of that stuff you have
original pages he's got Marvel just did
an exhibit a couple years ago at the EMP
what used to be the experience music
project in Seattle the museum that's
under the Space Needle
and as I went through the exhibits like
incredible rare [ __ ] pieces including
a Ditko one of Ditko's pages right
amazing fantasy but so many things had a
little like donated by Dave Mandel his
collection is mom he had the poster that
I did for the New Mutants with less
circuit boards and stuff like that in
the show and he's he's been very kind so
that you ever want to visit the stuff
you know the your work you know come on
by I smell a heist like he's married now
he's got a house and wife and kids and
stuff but when he got engaged and when
he got married he kept his apartment yes
like like it's not too far from where I
live but he didn't keep it to be like
I'm gonna spend weekends there that's
literally just where he keeps his
collectibles so he's got drawers and
drawers of like the most expensive comic
book art we're gonna plan it he's got an
original star stormtrooper helmet from a
new hope like one of the few that ever
leaked out into the world that stuff
he's got a like a grade-a collections
that the one with the paint the paint
flecks were they actually it was it was
not made out of the same color it was
like it was painted
that's that's you're talking super rare
and he got that a long time ago and I
remember when he got it this was like
years ago and he paid something like
what was then to me mind-bending like 15
grand I was like you got screwed that
thing's worth like a million dollars
today yeah yeah I say again I smell who
has been over a long career and you've
drawn a lot of cats including you did
amazing Batman covers from my widening
gyre run I'm still waiting for our
second second run ten years okay but
like I've got a lot of that artwork
hanging up with my house so I obviously
love you by me you did my onomatopoeia
covers as well there was like
mind-bending I look at him everyday and
stuff as well as use the cover for
evening with Kevin Smith three mm-hmm
across the spectrum both lay both the
big two everywhere you've ever worked
who's your favorite character to draw
Wow
it's like not to sort of evade the
question but it also kind of depends on
the day you know I mean they're our
favorite favorite okay Batman
[ __ ] you you you draw a [ __ ] out of
Batman dude all right and you paint the
[ __ ] out of Batman like you make that
Batman that just feels like what a
criminal on [ __ ] drugs would see when
they turned in the alley and Batman was
there just this imposing [ __ ] curling
organic figure that almost rises out of
the shadows well they were myth than man
thanks man well the the feeling that you
just mentioned that was really what I
felt like people have asked you know
what I feel separates my work from other
because there are people who can draw
rings around me it's like and I felt
like my goal was to draw well enough to
have something looks look like what it's
supposed to but I really care and again
maybe this is where the jazz comes into
it I really care more about what a
character feels like so if the character
is yelling you know you can like and you
see a lot of artists you know get into
comics and they'll use photo reference
and I'll have somebody yelling and it'll
be like
no it'll be sort of this tepid you know
half
you know half yell and I would rather
sort of dislocate the draw and just have
it be this this you know that Xavier yes
texting they're totally playing I never
look at that book and be like well
that's just unrealistic number one we're
dealing with characters that are
completely [ __ ] realistic to begin
with so to have dramatic expressions
makes the work [ __ ] memorable and
engages the reader on an emotional level
well that sort of ties back in to what I
said earlier about the the you know film
adaptations is sort of being a thankless
job I mean when I was doing dune they
said you know he's too heavy it's like
it's like you're telling me that if I
did an adaptation of this Superman movie
with you know with Christopher I have to
draw the wires holding them up no it's
like you can do anything in this medium
why are why are you sort of limiting me
so anyway Joker's always a kick to do
because he feels is in joke and an
Electra you know I'd say it has yeah I
it was a point when I was like I'm done
I can't do any more and I sort of felt
like with a lecture I sort of felt like
Nimoy felt like with Spock yeah it's
like okay this is like there are worse
things to be associated with you know
and and and it you know we're kind of a
way it's like I have no you know
allusions I mean I I I feel incredibly
fortunate and blessed I mean the fact
that I get to wake up every day and do
what I what I loved as a kid and the
pendant there's just so much more you
know and you're [ __ ] Mount Rushmore
name in the industry man like [ __ ] I
don't know about but I appreciate that
but I study you got a three-volume
register
so Volume one is on sale now right buy
ones on sale when to the other to come
out is there all three in one can I buy
them all now
no the second one we're actually is
starting on the second the second volume
you start on volume your beginning you
start working on to the volume 1 is
available volume 2 right and volume 1
comes in to two editions one is the
regular edition which is that book there
and then there's another limited edition
which comes with like 20 to 30 I'm
blanking on the exact number of art
prints as well so it's a big you know a
bigger package of limited edition stuff
so big numbers was that more that was
that with Allen yeah yeah what does an
Allen more script look like intimidating
it's it's everything that you've
probably heard about it's like what I
would work and was working with Frank
and and again I've been really fortunate
to work with so many of the greatest
writers I mean doug mensch
you know my first you know and doug was
very very complete and i think he was
also kind of given a thankless job
because i think they were like you know
right for the right for the idiot you
know give him everything you know and
when I worked the later issues I really
wanted to stretch I kind of felt
hamstrung because I wanted to be able to
say you look you want me to get your
character character from point A to
point B let me decide don't tell me like
how to get in there let me get you there
you know more freedom on the page
exactly yeah because when I was growing
up I used to write all of my comics I
used to write for my friends so I kind
of grew up in that what was sort of the
Filipino school you know where you're
writing lettering coloring doing all of
your stuff yourself and when you get
into comics when I got to the regular
mainstream stuff where it becomes more
of a Ford assembly line it's like Europe
penciler you know you're putting on the
windshield you're gonna be doing that
you know the headrests and the coffee
holders you know it was like working
with with Doug and then working with
with Chris Chris was very much about
plot so he left it wide open Frank
started off giving me pretty heavy too
scripts and then as we were working on
Elektra assassin he would give me a page
description like Garrett's
reconstruction and that would be it
you know so we gave you a lot of freedom
a lot of free that's an artist trusting
an artist so I'm like you know you're
doing whereas Allen would give me for a
48 page comic I mean literally it would
be an inch and a half thick and he would
he would have stories about background
characters having an argument and it
would go into their whole conversation I
mean he was writing a novel is really
what it was doing things that would
never really make it into the path to
the papers more for you it was yes it
was like oh my god this stuff is just
it's dense there's there's dense as in
lead and then there's neutron star dense
you know it was like and you know and
Allen was just like just push it in
there and he was really amazing and to
me that like you know bringing up Allen
the one thing that that sort of is my in
a career where I feel really really
fortunate my biggest regret is is the
big numbers not you know being being
finished that's right yeah that's like
that's not him correct well that was
like during the like I guess the 80s 90s
when you know minor digression here it's
like big numbers was really supposed to
be about chaos theory and how seemingly
you know the butterfly effect the whole
randomness of long before anybody was
dealing right in the movies exactly
great so it was really going to be about
you know things that seem like unrelated
but were all sort of tied together and
so I knew where all the characters were
going to end up and and it was actually
starting out in black and white was
supposed to go into a full color by the
end and I lived in Westport Connecticut
at the time and I used I think I needed
about 45 different characters to people
amongst I at that in that project I
wanted to do as close to photo realism
as I could
this is pre-digital like there was one
page that there was a coffee cup milk
you know I think it was in that issue no
not in that issue issue too but there
was one where a coffee cream was being
mixed into a cup of coffee done
breathtaking this house man well the
thing is is that that was all being
airbrushed and if I wanted to play with
focus you know there wasn't a blur
filter that I played with you know so
but what was strange about that is that
I had to hire and reach out to a bunch
of different artists and friends and
just people that I didn't even know to
act as as models and there was one
sequence in the issue one where there's
a bunch of little kids making Molotov
cocktails and I don't offending you know
what like Westport Connecticut is like
if you've ever read The Stepford Wives
and yeah and and Greenwich the last
thing you want to do when you're there
is to go up to a bunch of moms at a
playground and ask if you take
photographs of their kids especially to
have them like creating Molotov
cocktails you know it's like no no
they're gonna be making lemonade you
know so it what really happened was it
said because it was a story about chaos
the reason it fell apart was chaos I
mean life got crazy my parents passed
away it's like I broke up with my
girlfriend at the time it's like I
remember two of them of the people who
were posing for the characters one
drowned in the Long Island Sound he was
a bit one of those big brothers it took
his his kid out and like on a March it
was a very very bad weekend with a lot
of bad weather and their bodies washed
up on shore like six weeks later him and
the kid yeah and so it was like this
this weird thing where life imitating
art yeah it was it's like like a
perverse version or even more perverse
version of lost and Lamantia
you know by terry gilliam
we're so um fraught with peril
exactly cursed yeah so um I regret that
it didn't happen but you know it it was
still one of the one of the most
wonderful experiences it feels like in
completion is the perfect ending for a
story about Kay that's that's the this
sort of you know I I'm hesitating to say
it's kind of a poetic you know ending to
it maybe because it's a rationalization
on my part like it's meant not to end
it's very meta yeah but is there
anything or any character you have a
drawn yet like for somebody that you're
like oh I've always wanted to do that
I'm sure like you get Commission's all
time and I'm sure and you when you're
boards I was also a big sword and
Sworcery guy growing up I was a big you
know into into Robert E Howard and
Rosetta
so I always thought it'd be fun to do a
run on Conan for some reason you know no
and I did some covers yeah but they
always but Conan always ended up looking
like Clint Eastwood for me you know it's
like the Polish guy that's right yeah
well you soon was a big big Idol of you
know big hero to me in terms of like
saying more with less he's also a jazz
guy too so of the Marvel or DC where do
you fall now like you said like I like
DC it was safe you've done a [ __ ] ton of
Marvel work and redefine Marvel and
created [ __ ] IP that's still being
used today do you have a preference I
think not who's better to work for but
like where the character is better where
do you feel more at home I still I think
in a weird way me being sort of not
taken at DC was actually the like a
blessing I mean you know again I have
nothing against DC they've been
absolutely amazing to work with
and I love their characters but in terms
of my personality and and and everything
that I've done I can't take any credit
for without acknowledging all the
editors
like Ralph Macchio and Anna senti and an
even shooter you know shooter gave me a
lot of crap but he was like he would
fight for his freelancers he would bust
my chops with you know saying like you
you're using all of these muddy colors
you know but he would say you can't do
things like with the whole thing with
the with the kingpin he said it's not
going to be in the regular comic but
rather than just sort of crushing it he
said you know and killing it he said
let's do it as a graphic novel so he was
open to it so you know there's always so
many people who are there too if they if
they feel that you're honest and you
love what you're doing they will be
there to support you and push you and
and kind of clear the path for you so
for me I will always be indebted to you
know and I've made so many friends you
know during all the years when I was at
Marvel I mean the bullpen having
conversations with you know things that
you don't really see much of these days
you know you know going because now if
you go into any of the corporate offices
you've got to get like a blood sample
and a license you mean you know and I
mean back then I remember having a
conversation with Jack Abel who was an
anchor and a lot of romance stuff he did
and we got to a conversation about Roy
Lichtenstein about his paintings you
know 20 million-dollar paintings if
you've ever seen any of licken team
looks and steen stuff it's only recently
that that you see guys like Bernie
Wrightson making a million you know his
estate or not even his estate you know
the artists themselves are being you
know struggling for healthcare you know
but but I remember talking to Jack I
said well how do you feel about the fact
that you did these romance you know
panels he's a comment was just kind of
doing yeah he's doing he's running away
and he was very sanguine about it you
said I probably stole it from Wally wood
anyway yeah so it was you know these
kinds of things where you're you're
you're all kind of in this cocoon of
loving the medium and and like striving
to have comics be viewed as you know not
worth like you're standing on on
remote rocky hillside you know with your
hand nailed to your forehead about
comics being art you know where other
art forms can come in and sort of you
know what's the word you know access or
pay homage not even know much but just
sort of take from it and then just sort
of make a lot a lot of bank with it and
yet the medium itself is still viewed as
denigrated cuz you know I'm sure when
you guys were growing up in comics are
probably viewed as you know viewed while
we're in that kids should yeah exactly
yeah
where's to go to Europe it's like you
know they're you know they're reading it
right out in the open you know and and I
think a lot of that has changed but I
think that even in corporate structure I
think the corporation's sort of view the
comics side of things the same way a lot
of fans did I think they sort of don't
quite understand it you know it's like a
great a crazy group of sort of creative
kids doing stuff but dumb you are a
crazy creative kid who did a bunch of
stuff
he said well volume one where can they
get it I think I think it's probably
label it like most major book outlets
it's unavailable on Amazon and Amazon
I've never heard that yeah exactly so
the book is volume one the career is
absolutely legendary I if I could draw I
wouldn't have subjected people to those
horrible [ __ ] movies so my hat is
always off to anybody that can capture
graphics and hands down you were my one
of my favorite artists on the planet
thank you for coming oh my
ah [ __ ] man houses yes this is like
comics porn - just like names that are
like ah [ __ ]
okay do you got news depends if you got
time look at that [ __ ] Dazzler cover
man oh my god I know they don't want me
to sound right
there's the ROM cover there's [ __ ]
electric that just says yeah let's cover
let's cover some [ __ ] before I got a
bolt downtown and do some q and A's for
Jay and Silent Bob reboot at the Alamo
Drafthouse I'm gonna be cheatin on you
all tonight with some people at the
Alamo Drafthouse alright then we gonna
power through this news relatively
quickly [ __ ] a I won't say anything
about it no hey do you know what kind of
TV show is gonna be on the Disney pluse
in years to come what they got a new
show they have an announcer yeah or
they've just started to talk about okay
tell me were you a willow fan as a kid
yeah oh yeah this is an absolute [ __ ]
no-brainer man and that's a good place
for and [ __ ] I say this happily cuz my
dog is named Matt Mar together Wow right
is Ron Howard doing it I'm Ron Howard
will produce it Jonathan
Kasdan I think is writing that's [ __ ]
dope and that's some some of that news
that makes you happy where you're like
oh man good for them I believe in that I
had a feeling you would I don't know I
mean I'll catch up to it and [ __ ] when
it happens for sure like that's that's
so [ __ ] write up man you think they'd
bring Warwick Davis back they'd have to
yeah and he's still [ __ ] vital and and
yeah absolutely bring him back [ __ ] yeah
and like you know it turns out he's got
a kid willow to my daughter or something
she felt like right not without my
daughter yes exactly I mean and I guess
if you're gonna do that then like Laura
Dannon would probably be in her
early 20s maybe mid 20s right that makes
a ton of sense that movie I like that
Ron Howard's gonna get another bite at
that Apple mmm like it meant I remember
when it came out it meant the world to
him and it didn't like like the world on
fire I really dug it but it wasn't like
they thought it would be like this is
the next stars that's a movie eat of
George Lucas so well basically also Star
Wars it is kind of is medieval Star Wars
and stuff that's awesome man I like when
people could kind of go full circle come
back to some [ __ ] looks like he's got
some unfinished business and that's a
good idea man in a world where they did
the Dark Crystal absolutely do that
speaking of unfinished business Orlando
Jones who was one of the co-stars in
American Gods yeah he played the sort of
African trickster god and man see yes
and season two he was also part of the
show and had been sort of promoted to
both like producer and writer on the
show and apparently according to him was
fired for season three kind of without
warning kind of without sort of cause
and told to be quiet about it it's
happening back in September
he's decided not to be very quiet about
it and kind of took his grievances to
the Internet
what's the idea why did they is it one
of those we don't need his character
anymore but it's deeper than that yes
the statement by Fremantle which is the
sort of studio behind the show stars as
the network the the statement says the
character of mr. Nancy was not in the
sections of the book that we're adapting
so we've we've decided not to renew his
contract Orlando is saying that they've
decided that that particular character
who was the like angry gets [ __ ] done a
little bit of the not to say angry Negro
but angry Negro was not the vision of of
blackness they wanted to portray on the
show any longer and they felt that the
showrunner or at least he feels that the
showrunner feels that he could handle
all of the black people talking without
any black people on the staff
so I also saw something about was the
Gabrielle Union is yeah who also
America's Got Talent was also a
Fremantle show and so apparently though
they're both free medals and I both
Fremantle shows so yes you're a little
bit too black for us and they throw
their hair with good work yeah so it is
119 I'm just checking yeah yeah no so
it's weird for this to all sort of come
out when like Watchmen is having this
very serious conversation about race and
class and value and pain a lesson that
apparently Fremantle it hasn't quite
wrap their heads around
so yeah it's it is not that this sort of
thing doesn't happen because it does
with frightening regularity who gave me
this weed who are you a new best friend
who are you do this what's the story
behind this weed and does it go with
this photo of this image look at this
[ __ ] man hold on one second we just hold
it up for everyone to see Jesus Christ
look who it is it's our princess oh wow
that's gorgeous you you did this and
what'd you do listen to you you're like
well you know I'm [ __ ] help she did
the hard amazing is gorgeous I'm
literally hanging this up in my house
man you got a [ __ ] great eye and you
know what you go bleep pretty well that
is really that's got get crazy he copper
Leafs very much yeah my bad my bad oh
that's [ __ ] gorgeous kids well done
thank you and then what's the story
behind this
IIIi don't know you know what I am a
pothead you're absolutely right first I
was gonna chafe at that but I'm like now
that's me we Co totally can I don't know
what I'm happier about man I first I saw
the weed now is excited but this is
legit gorgeous man my wife is gonna let
me hang this up that's the bar for
everything my wife is like get that off
the wall but she'll [ __ ] love this
and look at her man you have arresting
and power as a beautiful piece excellent
[ __ ] job [ __ ] I didn't bring you
anything do I have anything what is it
you guys are too sweet
thanks look at that that's tremendous
and mine look you got an afterthought
and mark barnard oh yeah whatever I'll
come visit that at your house okay what
else
Marvel TV is officially no more yeah man
let's pour one out for for our yellow
man who carried that [ __ ] like across
two cavalry man for like almost a decade
he was like doing it and come on we got
some great shows out of that as well
what is this about Simon had oh I was
just like are we doing bets or something
on the inside of the brim core inside
pound I'm gonna insert my ferrell film
this side here or inside inside I just
don't want to [ __ ] it up where you're
like now I got a stupid signature all
over you I'll go this side this is nice
man it's [ __ ] dope yeah Marvel TV is
no more Jeph Loeb had announced that he
was going to be leaving the company a
few months back and it's still not clear
what his date of departure Oh for me -
yeah you're good son as well I'm gonna
[ __ ] up the front of your head haha
the Jeff I spoke to him about it not too
long ago he wasn't like [ __ ] he was like
this is cool I'm ready to do something
but you know thank you
remember we're now coming into an age
where you know Kevin Feige he's got the
the Marvel shows on Disney Plus and
they're gonna be [ __ ] amazing
everything I've heard about Juan
divisionist
[ __ ] incredible that being said like
there was a time where like we were so
[ __ ] delighted to have a legit
wonderful daredevil and that came from
Jeff we were so excited maybe I was to
have legit wonderful Runaways I
absolutely love that [ __ ] show that
came from them a lot of people love
agents of shield I can't [ __ ] them
like the list goes on and on and like
they were they were carrying the torch
and and trying to connect them to the
movies when they were allowed and stuff
like that I thought they did a wonderful
job
like the whole way there's nobody leaves
that operation with shame and I'll be
honest with you like it makes absolute
sense what they're doing to put it all
under Kevin Feige like he's got the
movies now he's got the TV shows and the
comic books it sounds like you're gonna
be under him as well that makes absolute
[ __ ] sense that being said it takes
nothing away from all the great work
that Jeff and Marvel television have
done for the last 10 years give it up
for Jeff yeah Marvel TV man now Marvel
TV won't cease to exist it's just
becoming this difference folding under
Marvel Studios and some of the same
executives are still going to be there
shows so it's not quite gone but it's
not exactly what it was at one point I
hear the Hulu shows are still alive so
so far so good for Howard the Duck I'll
let you know if anything happens yeah
it's it's guys I think ultimately it's
it's sad you know to see an era come to
an end but I kind of look forward to see
what they're doing next absolutely
nothing lasts forever yeah unless you
have made a movie that gets voted into
the Library of Congress's National Film
registry of which every year they choose
25 to the
restored and venerated and kept among
the most important works of cinematic
art one person who's standing behind
this bar had a movie voted into the
National Film registry this past week
that was that that person is meet ladies
that person is you
[Applause]
hi it was 2:00 in the morning I forget
which city I was in but I was just about
to go to bed and Claire King who has
been she's Legion mcat who's been with
me like all throughout the making this
movie and promoting it one night she
built the quick stop at pecans this year
and stuff brought it down to San Diego
as well she tweeted at like 2:00 in the
morning she was like what a [ __ ] year
you're having and I clicked on the
article and I saw that I had no idea
that was coming you can't even plan for
that sort of [ __ ] nor can you dream
about that sort of [ __ ] because that's
just like [ __ ] so far-fetched but
when I read that [ __ ] I wept I felt like
you know honestly I was like I'm safe
like I'm I'm nobody could take this [ __ ]
away anymore man like as you heard from
bill before like we're from New Jersey
and for whatever reason because you grow
up in the shadow of something far larger
than yourself which is New York which is
right next door and stuff you never
think you're [ __ ] good enough so it
makes you try harder and [ __ ] like that
it makes you strive for more but also
kind of makes you miserable inside some
days where you can't just enjoy some
[ __ ] because you're always worried if
it's going to be taken away from you
did I really earn it [ __ ] like was
anybody gonna care years from now Chet
that moment made me feel like oh [ __ ]
I'm safe we did it like [ __ ] nobody
could take that 25 years away man like
it was real so beautiful so I can't
thank folks enough it was a public vote
and the public voted up it was the most
the most votes that the most public
votes most public for any of the 25
movies voted in and Christopher Downey
who directed the shooting clerks biopic
is a movie about how we made clerks back
in the day he was the guy I remember
seeing a tweet where he was like let's
get this in the national registry and I
was like you poor son of a [ __ ] that's
what a waste of time that's for better
people and she liked it don't throw your
vote away but it [ __ ] worked out man
and I it was that with putting my hands
in the cement at the Chinese Theatre
like those are two things I never saw
coming but really make me feel like oh I
wasn't a fluke man like [ __ ] were
part of it now like we're you know we're
in the book that feels [ __ ] great so
it was absolutely [ __ ] magical and I
heard from a bunch of people like that I
hadn't heard from in a long time and
stuff it was really really [ __ ]
special like in a world where like my
job in is to catch attention because I'm
in sales I sell Kevin Smith for a living
and stuff and you premeditate in a lot
of cases like I'm gonna do this article
because I want to sell these tickets and
[ __ ] like that and sometimes it's hard
to get traction or Inc or something like
that
I got a round of free [ __ ] press for
something that I did like a quarter
century ago it was really [ __ ] nice
for a guy who believes in like work
smarter not harder I didn't have to do
anything the 21 year old [ __ ] Kevin
Smith who started me on this journey he
did all the [ __ ] hard work and stuff
so when it happened and when I read that
I when I got emotional and cried it
wasn't so much for me that felt cool I
felt safe I felt I'm so good for that
kid this would mean the world to him
then that people treated that movie
seriously
holy [ __ ] so yeah I was very very
special thing yes and other other films
in this particular class The Last Waltz
Coal Miner's Daughter my [ __ ] dais
yes Milo's Foreman's Amadeus which I
love Coal Miner's Daughter my father
took me to see twice in a movie theater
I absolutely dearly loved that movie so
when I saw that I was in the category
with that we were in one of the 25
movies with Coal Miner's Daughter
I felt [ __ ] fantastic then I saw
Spike Lee she's got to have it yeah and
Spike Lee he's a big part of why I do
what I do and then her purple [ __ ]
Rain Man are you kidding me like I'm
telling you the kid that made clerks
would be [ __ ] beside himself and the
guy who [ __ ] was the kid who made
clerks like it's beside himself to like
it was just wonderful to be included in
any list let alone that one man and my
old man he's been long dead and [ __ ] but
this would have gave him such a [ __ ]
I was gonna say hard-on but it sounds
weird for the dad like he loved this
kind of [ __ ] like for him to be like
you've been recognized by the government
even this government like it'll be a
cool thing so it is nice to be involved
nice to be in the Library of Congress
like that means if the aliens come and
blow everything up there's a copy of
clerk still waiting man so oK we've got
to save it at all cost that's the news
my friend as the news it's the new let's
see what time we go 10:30 I could do it
I could do a couple questions as I Drive
terribly and fast Oh Shane what do we
got to give away let's say we got 40 X
tickets from our good friend Brent Oh
our fantastic friend Brett Deacon who
works over 40's has grabbed tickets for
us to give away if you've not seen a
movie in 40 acts are they doing Star
Wars they are doing Star Wars kids I've
been [ __ ] look I don't know many
times I got to tell you about 40x man
this is a theater a movie seat that will
blow you practically it's unbelievable
shoots [ __ ] mist in your face
everything [ __ ] stinks it's fantastic
this is an amazing way to see a movie
but if you've never seen a movie go see
[ __ ] Star Wars with your 40 X tickets
man those we got Xbox game passes good
for one month unlimited access to over
100 high-quality games from the good
folks at Xbox holy [ __ ] who where do we
get this I got those you did yeah who
[ __ ] who do you know man look at this
it seems like Xbox like some black man
and then of course our own Dark Knight
Returns Nate Gonzales did these amazing
Watchmen prints one of my favorite
aspects of this show we do here is
there's this is so punk rock every
[ __ ] show Nate has created artwork for
us man that always makes me feel [ __ ]
young and vital and like I said I wish I
could draw but I can't I'm so glad I
know people that can so you're gonna get
one of these as well man if we get to
answer your question is that all oh [ __ ]
no I got [ __ ] to give away holy [ __ ]
look at this
Jay and Silent Bob have games man from
the good folks at place storm these are
card games and this one is called Jay
and Silent Bob's big fat card on game
you sit there you put these questions
together like different powers of comic
book characters and [ __ ] like you're an
Avenger of the night and a guy who swims
underwater and saves fishes we can't say
the real names because that's [ __ ]
expensive so you match those powers and
then you see which one could do what man
it's like he's sitting around with your
friends go and imagine you're like who'd
beat this guy this guy or this guy it's
that [ __ ] game so you get one of
those you'll also get not one but two
[ __ ] games also from the good folks
at play storm this game is called the
Jay and Silent Bob
smell my finger game in this game you
got fake fingers man and you put them on
your hand and you take any scent you
want here in the bar there'd be lots of
liquor to choose from you can stick it
in [ __ ] you could stick it up your
ass and then you played a game where you
like smell my finger and they have to
guess it properly man so I mean
technically you could do it without the
game you could just do it with your own
fingers but plug in its got cards and
steaks and [ __ ] so the good folks are
placed storm did this with us man so
you'll get copy that game as well all
right now every question three go man
and then I got a [ __ ] race down town
and [ __ ] like that all right our first
one is DJ Clue low DJ where are you man
give it up for DJ everybody hello a DJ
hi happy Star Wars week yes I've seen it
already man I want to tell you something
there's [ __ ] well [ __ ] I've seen it
twice already
zip you saw twice yeah my so my question
actually comes with a story about Star
Wars
okay believe it so it starts with a
short story it's a little bit lighter so
bear with me
so 2015 huge Star Wars fan force awakens
coming out about a week before our force
awakens comes out my mom has to go in
for surgery
oh and for Locke I gave her a bb-8 charm
for a bracelet and she unfortunately
couldn't go see the movie with me and
thought it was a big deal
unfortunately a week after she passed
away there was so much [ __ ] so and it
was of course very hard me and her we're
very close and it really just knocked
the wind out of me
I'm an artist I was doing conventions
across the country you know I really
kind of hit me into a depression then
fast forward a year on the day
anniversary of my mom's death
we lost Carrie Fisher so it's like two
for two it's going great at that point I
was just like home I I left my career I
had worked for Disney for a long time I
left there moved back home to be with my
dad and I gave up my drawing I gave up
my career I had and I'm just in a
depression and then the next year on
next anniversary last Jedi comes out
I love the film but I am in like my
lowest low then something happened and
that something is this Kevin I've been a
fan of you for a long time and devotion
to your podcast and you're driven to
inspire people to do the things they
love to push themselves to do podcasts
or to do art or whatever it is and then
this incarnation of the show happened
where the two of you got together and
people would come and ask you questions
and you would give life advice
and I listened every week or every two
weeks when this episode would come out
and I'd listen to it driving to my job
that I now hated and it really just
pushed me pushed me to a new level of
what I can do and who I can be and I was
like you know what my mom's no longer
here to inspire me but you guys were so
I want to come over the bar I can hug
you man
but keep could keep going so then fast
forward in a year again and I applied
for my dream job on the anniversary of
my mom's death and I'm proud to say for
this entire year I now work for
Lucasfilm [ __ ] a man so that is
[ __ ] proof we're living in a right
simulation right now [ __ ] well done
so if you want to talk about we're going
to Skywalker later I can totally do it
yes oh [ __ ] you've seen it about the
record mm-hmm so because of you guys and
talking to your fans and giving that
advice about what should I do maybe a
write better writer what should I do to
be an artist you know through that it
silently drove me and I was here for the
premiere and Mark you posted to the show
was happening and I was like a hall it's
destiny this is so weird
I have to go and I bought it to get
instantly yeah I so wanted to tell you
guys thank you because of everything
you've done I know work in a galaxy far
far away
[Applause]
number one that's awesome and you're
definitely winning the the stuff we're
giving away but number two can you get
us a job can I see the movie yeah a few
more days you know what is it like
working for him it seemed like a great
oh he's a really surreal you know I grew
up being a fan and in my dream I went to
art school cuz I wanted to work at
LucasArts and I actually went to college
in San Francisco for a year and school
was horrible so I left art school and I
never thought I thought I'd lost my
opportunity the work and Star Wars that
worked for Lucasfilm and then I just got
crazy lucky but it's amazing being up
there at the Presidio at the campus
walking through those halls with legends
with ILM legends I see John Knoll every
day whoa
Dennis Muren all them whoa the names of
my childhood man there's a rock star
names people whose names I knew before I
got in this business and [ __ ] and those
are people that are like them it seems
people they still loom large as [ __ ]
rock stars I met Dennis Muren it's
[ __ ] awesome he's very tall huge right
yes he looks like the lava I think the
craziest thing was it was like couple
weeks back I there's no there's a
bathroom across the hall from my office
and I walked out and I walked in the
bathroom and there's someone washing my
hands washing their hands good and I
just looked to see if it was somebody no
they say hi and it was uh was the maker
was George Lucas and I just did that
thing where I'm like not a good time to
say hello to him not me I would have
been like let me see your dick let me
see your lightsaber George
so I eat remember me it's no dr.
Manhattan but I thought he smelled bad
on the outside so I did my business and
I ran back to my office like guys George
Lucas is in the bathroom George Lucas
urinate and they're just like yeah he
owns the building okay so that was crazy
and then I went to the cafeteria later
that day and he was sitting at a table
ten feet from me you know Dave Filoni is
right here John Knoll and I'm just like
what is my life now so it's been surreal
and I bet his mom would be so thank you
very [ __ ] cool thank you so much so I
my question I always love how that ends
with people say these inspiring stories
in they go but there's one more thing
give me more so that's my story for you
guys was there somebody in your life
maybe someone you didn't know directly a
hero that inspired you to just pick it
up and go you know what I can do it I
can do it and I'm going to and then
dreams happen Richard Linklater hands
down I saw slacker and that's the movie
that made me go well maybe I could make
a movie and then I read all about his
journey which wasn't easy at the time
because there was no internet and stuff
but I tracked down articles and [ __ ]
any book I could get my hands on and
stuff but he made me believe it was
possible he made me believe in myself
and not like he was never sat me down
and said Kevin believe in yourself it's
just I saw his movie and it spoke to me
on some level of like oh my god like
[ __ ] you know if that's a if that's a
movie I think I can make a [ __ ] movie
to it just made it seem possible
so yeah hands down I'm not standing here
unless Richard Linklater sings this song
that enabled me to save myself I was
working at The Hollywood Reporter I was
an editor I wanted to write television
I'd written a bunch of pilots you know
the gun progressively better as
does but I hadn't had any success like
there was no nothing was breaking my way
and I was lucky enough to get to
interview I did a cover story on Damon
Lindelof
right about when like alien covenant was
coming out and leftovers was starting up
and and and like we kind of hit it off
it's been a couple days with them and
like Tomorrowland I think was on the
horizon and like a couple weeks after
that maybe about a month after that I
like just violated every bit of
journalistic ethics and it's an email
saying hey listen I know you're staffing
up on leftovers I wonder if you might
consider me for that room he said
alright well [ __ ] it ok send me a script
and I said pilot that I'd written and
you know about a week later he emails me
he says listen I'm always hesitant to
ask people to read [ __ ] because you know
there's almost no good outcome for that
because either like it's good rarely or
it's bad and I have to figure out a way
to tell you that you can't write it's
like luckily I don't have to tell you
that like you can write like you have
talent and I said listen like I know you
don't know me from Adam but I'm thinking
about giving up because it's just too
hard the odds are too long I don't know
if I'm ever gonna make this happen
and he said now is not the time to give
up and now's the time to double down
he's like you have the talent you just
and you can't control the timing and the
only way to be prepared for that is to
keep going and I'm convinced that if
somebody hadn't told me that at that
moment I would have given up it happened
to be him and the fact that like he then
became a friend and I get to interview
him about [ __ ] Watchmen which he
didn't hire me for but that's a whole
nother thing little [ __ ] man feel like
he cracked open my world and gave me
everything didn't hire me for Watchmen
or whatever
that's all right there's no white season
- oh this is true that's true but just
like sometimes you need that one person
at that time to tell you keep going you
know like it's it's not futile it's not
worth giving up you can do this you just
need to wait for the brass ring to come
around for you and when it comes grab it
and for me he was that guy at that time
BAM
you win a prize man take it my friend
take this pie
alright JC where we going Melissa
Lambert
Melissa Lambert get up here Melissa
everyone give it up for Melissa she
might be next well she definitely next
we'll see if she can surprise hi a fan
shouts my brother it's his birthday
Matthew and this question is actually
for my husband I actually didn't come up
with it myself
he's my husband you reached it Jason I
was like I've only been gone two months
like he's serving in the Navy on the
other side of the country so I thought
I'd ask this for hang out [ __ ] wait
wait where is he he's in Louisiana doing
what he's in the Navy he's a corpsman
thank inversely yeah so we been watching
Watchmen together and it was really
inspiring but what cultural event or
idea would you want to educate an
audience on with an IP like Tulsa 21 and
Watchmen which IP would you guys choose
and white IP plus cultural event
okay oh all right
i stumped mark hold on yeah no you
really [ __ ] asked a very classy
question and we weren't prepared for
that at all no none of my back pocket
dick jokes are gonna work man I'm I'm
gonna have to dip a dig Damon Lindelof
deep on this one but I'm waiting on you
oh [ __ ] you usually have something so
smart to say like but it's two things
now it's not just like I gotta find the
event and then I got to find [ __ ] all
right okay I broke the rules ask two
questions now on no there it was an
enigma inside of a mystery inside of a
puzzle box all right I can't do Watchmen
I can't do the Tulsa massacre but the IP
I would choose is a man for all seasons
which is the Thomas More Robin bull play
about Thomas Moore and they made it into
a movie and how it would be what was the
second question
what could you deal with I guess it
would be like talking about brexit God
all of that sounded so [ __ ] white
okay I got one
go save it uh it's a it's not a specific
ghost story it is a ghost story though
but during the Revolutionary War there
is a very precarious moment when the the
cause was almost lost when the George
Washington's army was trapped on Long
Island on Brooklyn honestly and the
entire British Navy was between Brooklyn
and the mainland and Brooklyn is on Long
Island so it's an island it's sort of
you know I'm surrounded by water and the
British Army was moving in and the
American the the Revolutionary Army was
just about to get wiped out and so they
had to stage this last-minute crazy
[ __ ] escape over the the bay into New
Jersey and they would have all died if
it wasn't for like this bank of fog that
happens to roll in that covers their
escape from nightfall to dawn and
literally like George Washington is on
the last [ __ ] boat to New Jersey as
the fog lifts and the British Army rolls
in and everything is gone
canons horses you know 5,000 men if that
doesn't happen there is no America and
it happened
it's ridiculous and so if there's a New
Jersey was involved New Jersey is [ __ ]
invalid but like I always kind of wanted
to do a story about like George
Washington his confidant during that
entire experience was a slave because
again [ __ ] 1782 and white people but I
always thought it'd be interesting if
that slave was a ghost you know and so
he's confiding into this person who is
not that telling people this story wants
to save this and [ __ ] do it cuz she
asked me a question
I know [ __ ] like that's great in the
Navy
that's good point you need to do this
that's [ __ ] tight dude I tried to sell
it as a graphic novel and who didn't buy
that a Bob Shrek at Bob you didn't
[ __ ] clerks the comic book off at
some point you should that's a [ __ ] I
didn't know that story
yeah that's dope great question way
better answer than mine you get a prize
take this all back yeah we settle oh all
right Big Daddy Jimmy V oh sorry you
know well that's fair do you want to
hear his question nope nope we came here
to ask it I don't want to know it go
ahead you gotta back up I've got a bag
up yeah all right you caught you
get the [ __ ] up here Sidney get up there
right now come on real [ __ ] far give
it up for Sidney you can do it man
captain how are you don't walk past me
Sidney now we're good day as they said
pleasure come on up to the wall join us
man
Sidney it's [ __ ] beautiful if you've
never been there you take off from Los
Angeles you land in Sidney and you think
you just landed in Los Angeles again
it's beautiful it looks exactly like Los
Angeles I took off I saw a Westfield
Mall I landed I saw Westfield Mall all
right one world first off it's it's
great to meet you both
where's your [ __ ] accent man yeah I'm
from Boston
my girlfriend's from Torrance we both
live in Sydney now how'd that happen
it's the long story this podcast runs
and you've got some places to go so
that's true my question was given the
expansion of the Star Wars Canon in the
last couple of years there are a lot of
lessons outside of the original trilogy
oh yeah that resonate with us fans which
ones resonate with you personally and
which ones would you expand on the Asoka
storyline is my favorite aspect of Star
Wars I think even more so than perhaps
like the movies themselves at this point
her storyline was absolutely fantastic
then they touched on it again years
later like and she fought Darth Vader
yeah yeah oh my god it was a is one of
the best [ __ ] Star Wars anything that
has ever happened in this world if
you've never seen the that was that
happening rebels began and Clone Wars
and Clone Wars is coming back so we're
gonna get more so good there is I read
an article JJ did an interview and
somebody said hey man is there any
ahsoka and in this movie and the rise of
Skywalker and he indicated positively
that there's if you pay attention there
there is a souca moment and I saw the
movie and I can attest to that
where I was like like that's the kind of
fanservice they're doing I love her
storyline I would I
I'd love to see her brought into the
into the movies and I think I saw the
first step toward that and especially
because that storyline is epic it's you
know they're always trying to tie it
into the old [ __ ] and whatnot that ties
directly into Anakin Skywalker Dave
Filoni who directed the first and fourth
episodes I believe if Mandalorian of
Mandalorian mando mando maker himself
he's instrumental in creating that
character if he didn't create or
single-handedly and when that dude is
now like rising to power in that place
he's always been the animation guy but
now he's moving into the live-action and
stuff and he got to cut his teeth in
animation where people like do what you
want and he told some of the most
imaginative [ __ ] Star Wars stories
that have been told so maybe he's the
guy who gets to bring his creation from
one medium and to the other that would
be breathtaking for me I say ahsoka you
when we first started to see the
trailers for rogue one you know we we
[ __ ] pocket I said bad cuz of course
we did what else we have done about it
yeah and I was theorizing that jyn erso
was because you saw her in this like
black flight suit as she's sort of
making her way into the scare off'
headquarters and I'm like what if what
if that is the pilot of one of the TIE
fighters the one that knocks into
Vader's TIE fighter
in the trench run I remember you said
that yeah I'm the podcast I was a girl
you just made a better movie because
there's a scene where like you know
they're flying is like I'm on the leader
and that is the TIE fighter the
Knoxville with the weirdest James Earl
Jones performance moment and all that
what [ __ ] your grandpa but I think
there is still an interesting story
about like that TIE fighter pilot like
is that a hat what did they do that in
tagging bait not that aspect were they
the two dudes who were on his [ __ ]
flank
Kenworthy is a genius Kevin Rubio did
troops and he also did tag and bank and
tag and bake is kind of like Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern in the Star Wars
universe well I want tagging binky you
just read it it's definitely I forgot
that's right they do he's there in the
[ __ ] ship and [ __ ] so that's my thing
then [ __ ] it's been it's a great [ __ ]
call not even great [ __ ] question
that's the best Australian accent I've
ever give it up for my eyes gentlemen
you win a package of stuff god damn
pleasure that is a girlfriend worth
keeping man she's like an agent get your
ass out there yeah that's your [ __ ]
question that's [ __ ] phenomenal yeah
somebody oh my god ladies and gentlemen
we got talked about a lot we got to see
a lot we got to hear a lot and [ __ ] did
you all have a good time this evening
[Applause]
sounds like we're gonna try to do this
when Sunday the 22nd so JC I'll put up
tickets get some tickets and whatnot
we'll spread the word we'll let
everybody know that you got to see
[ __ ] rise of Skywalker cuz we're
gonna spoil the [ __ ] out of it but we'll
sit around as a Sunday Sunday afternoon
or evening JC we're gonna sit around on
a Sunday afternoon talk about [ __ ]
Star Wars man how amazing will that be
come on out it'll be a good time thank
you for being here tonight there is no
nice to be back after so many [ __ ]
months yeah give it up for the guy who
has held down the [ __ ] fort and
elevated the fort mr. mark barnard it
and that is fat man beyond for this week
man I'm Kevin Smith I'm moving on to the
next time same bat-time same bat-channel
SModcast calm or you to become slash
Kevin Smith may the force be with you
everybody good I
[Applause]
[Music]
you